[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey there, gang, great
to see you again.
So I want you to check this out.
In this app, I have a
view that it can rotate
around using a rotate gesture.
Probably if you've done any
sort of gesture work before,
this looks pretty
standard to you.
But as you can see
here, my object
is always rotating
around its center.
Now, in many cases,
this make sense
and matches up with what
your users are expecting.
But there might be
times where you want
something a little different.
For example, there
may be times I'd
want to rotate my view around
where my user's fingers are,
instead of the view center.
Well, how would I do that?
Well, that's where this
episode's quick tip comes in.
And as you may have guessed
from the title here,
it's all about
using anchor points.
An anchor point of a view
is a local coordinate system
that goes from 0 to 1
in the x- and y-axes.
When you manipulate a view
using CGAffine Transform, which
is the way you would typically
rotate or scale a view,
iOS calculates
the transformation
based on the view's
anchor point.
By default, every
view's anchor point
is set to 0.5, 0.5, or the
exact center of the view, which
means that by default,
any rotation you get
from the CGAffine Transform is
calculated around this center
point.
However, I can change the
anchor point for my view
by setting the core animation
layer's anchor point property.
So going back to my
application, where
I want the view to rotate
around my two fingers,
I can look at where the
user's two touches are
relative to the view and
calculate the midpoint
of those two points.
Then I divide the x and
y values of that midpoint
by the width and height of
my view to normalize them.
And then I've got
an anchor point
that reflects the midway
point between my two fingers.
And so now if I set
my view's layer's
anchorPoint to be
this new value,
I should be able to rotate
it by one of its corners.
So let's see this in action.
Huh, well, uh, that's weird.
It does look like my view
is now rotating around
its corner instead of its
center, which is what I wanted.
But it's also jumping
around as soon
as I change its anchor point.
Well, why is it doing that?
Well, the answer basically
boils down to the fact
that core animation places views
based on their anchor points.
So when I change my
view's anchor point,
iOS tries to make sure
that anchor point is
in the same place
in its superview
as it was before, which means
that it shifts my view's
frame around.
And that's exactly what
happened in my app.
So how can you fix this?
Well, the easiest way is to
translate your view immediately
before or after you
change your anchor point.
Basically, figure
out the difference
between your old anchor point
and your new anchor point,
and shift your
view by that much.
Then, when you change
your anchor point,
iOS shifts your view
in the other direction.
Those two shifts
cancel each other out,
and your view will go back
to its original place.
Incidentally, I do recommend
applying this shift
as a CGAffine
transform, instead of
trying to move the
view's frame directly.
Otherwise you can end
up in weird situations
where your move gets
affected by the rotation,
and things just end
up all sorts of messy.
So if I try this now in my
app, where I immediately
translate my view and then
move the anchor point,
we get something like this.
Ah, well, that's
exactly what I wanted.
Incidentally, once you're
done rotating an object,
you can either leave its anchor
point at its new position
or reset it back to
the center again,
depending on whether you
think other methods might
be manipulating this view.
After all, some other animation,
like a scale animation,
might be assuming that
your view's anchor point is
in the center, and you
don't want to throw it off.
So today's quick
tip was brought you
by Jeff Verkoeyen, one
of the main authors
of the popular open
source library NimbusKit.
Jeff is also working on a number
of cool graphics and animation
libraries here inside of Google.
So thank you to Jeff.
And you know what?
Even though you
already work here,
I'll send you a t-shirt anyway
because I'm nice like that.
But what about you?
Do have a quick tip?
If you do, send it to me.
If I end up using
it in the video,
I will send you a T-shirt.
Listen, I've seen
engineers at conferences
like knock small children
out of the way in order
to get themselves
a free T-shirt,
so trust me when I say it'll
be a whole lot easier for you
to just mail me a tip, and
no children will get hurt.
So go on, I believe in you.
You can do it.
And as for the rest of
you, I will see you soon
on "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]